a few years ago I was taking care of a
woman who was a victim of violence I
wanted her to be seen in a clinic that
specialized in trauma survivors I made
the appointment myself because being the
director of the department I knew if I
did it she would get an appointment
right away the clinic was about an hour
and a half away from where she lived but
she took down the address and agreed to
go unfortunately she didn't make it to
the clinic when I spoke to the
psychiatrist he explained to me that
trauma survivors are often resistant to
dealing with the difficult issues that
they face and often miss appointments
for this reason they don't generally
allow the doctors to make appointments
for the patients they had made a special
exception for me when I spoke to my
patient
she had a much simpler and less Freudian
explanation of why she didn't go to that
appointment her ride didn't show now
some of you may be thinking didn't she
have some other way of getting to that
clinic appointment couldn't she have
taken an uber or called another friend
if you're thinking that it's probably
because you have resources but she
didn't have enough money for an uber she
didn't have another friend to call but
she did have me and I was able to get
her another appointment which she kept
without difficulty
she wasn't resistant it's just her I
didn't show I wish I could say that this
was an isolated incident but I know from
running the safety net systems in San
Francisco Los Angeles and now New York
City that healthcare is built on a
middle-class
model that often doesn't meet the needs
of low-income patients that's one of the
reasons why it's been so difficult for
us to close the disparity in healthcare
that exists along economic lines
despite the expansion of health
insurance under the ACA or Obamacare
health care in the United States assumes
that besides getting across the large
land expanse of Los Angeles it also
assumes that you can take off from work
in the middle of the day to get care one
of the patients who came to my East Los
Angeles clinic on a Thursday afternoon
presented with partial blindness in both
eyes very concerned I said to him when
did this develop he said Sunday said
Sunday did you think of coming sooner to
clinic and he said well I have to work
in order to pay the rent a second
patient to that same clinic a trucker
drove three days with a raging infection
only coming to see me after he had
delivered his merchandise both patient's
care was jeopardized by their delays in
seeking care healthcare in the United
States assumes that you speak English or
can bring someone with you who can in
San Francisco I took care of a patient
on the inpatient service who was from
West Africa and spoke a dialect so
unusual that we could only find one
translator on the telephonic line who
could understand him and that translator
only worked one afternoon a week
unfortunately my patient needed
translation services every day
healthcare in the United States assumes
that you're literate I learned that a
patient of mine who spoke English
without accent
was illiterate when he asked me to
please sign a social security disability
form for him right away the form needed
to go to the office that same day and I
wasn't in clinic so trying to help him
out
knowing that he was the sole caretaker
of his son I said we'll bring the form
to my administrative office I'll sign it
and I'll fax it in for you
he took the two buses to my office
dropped off the forearm went back home
to take care of his son I got to the
office and what did I find next to the
big X on the form the word applicant he
needed to sign the form and so now I had
to have him take the two buses back to
the office sign the form so that we
could then fax it in for him completely
changed how I took care of him I made
sure that I always went over
instructions verbally with him it also
made me think about all of the patients
who receive reams and reams of paper or
spit out by our modern electronic health
record systems explaining their
diagnosis and their treatments and
wondering how many people actually can
understand what's on those pieces of
paper health care in the United States
assumes that you have a working
telephone and an accurate address the
proliferation of inexpensive cell phones
has actually helped quite a lot but
still my patients run out of minutes and
their phones get disconnected low-income
people often have to move around a lot
by necessity
I remember reviewing a chart of a woman
with a abnormality on her mammogram the
chart assiduously documents that three
letters were sent to her home asking her
to please come in for follow-up of
course if the address isn't accurate it
doesn't much matter how many letters you
send to that same address health care in
the United States assumes that you have
a steady supply of food
this is particularly an issue for
diabetics we give them medications that
lower their blood sugar on days when
they don't have enough food it puts them
at risk for a life-threatening side
effect of hypoglycemia or low blood
sugar healthcare in the United States
assumes that you have a home with a
refrigerator for your insulin a bathroom
where you can wash up a bed where you
can sleep without worrying about
violence while you're resting but what
if you don't have that what if you live
on the street you live onto the freeway
you live in a congregate shelter where
every morning you have to leave at 7 or
8 a.m. where do you store your medicines
where do you use the bathroom how do you
put your legs up if you have congestive
heart failure is it any wonder that
providing people with health insurance
who are homeless does not erase the huge
disparity between the homeless and the
house health care in the United States
assumes that you prioritize your health
care but what about all of you let me
assume for a moment that you're all
taking a medication maybe it's for high
blood pressure maybe it's for diabetes
or depression what if tonight you had a
choice you could have your medication
but live on the street or you could be
housed in your home but not have your
medication which would you choose I know
which one I would choose this is
just a graphic example of the kinds of
choices that low-income patients have to
make every day so when my doctor's shake
their heads and say I don't know why
that patient didn't keep his follow-up
appointment I don't know why she didn't
go for that exam that I ordered I think
well maybe her ID didn't show or maybe
he had to work but also maybe there was
something more important that day then
their high blood pressure or a screening
colonoscopy
maybe that patient was dealing with an
abusive spouse or a daughter who was
pregnant
and drug addicted or a son who was
kicked out of school or even maybe they
were riding their bicycle through an
intersection and got hit by a truck and
now they're using a wheelchair and have
very limited mobility obviously these
things also happen to middle-class
people but when they do we have
resources that enable us to deal with
these problems we also have the belief
that we will live out our normal
lifespans that's not true for low-income
people they've seen their friends and
relatives die young of accidents of
violence of cancers that should have
been diagnosed at an earlier stage it
can lead to a sense of hopelessness that
it doesn't really matter what you do I
know I've painted a bleak picture of the
care of low-income patients but I want
you to know how rewarding I find it to
work in a safety net system and my deep
belief that we can make the system
responsive to the needs of low-income
patients the starting point has to be to
meet patients where they are provide
services without obstacles and provide
patients what they need not what we
think they need
it's impossible for me to take good care
of a patient who is homeless and living
on the street the right prescription for
a homeless patient is housing in Los
Angeles we housed 4700 chronically
homeless persons suffering from medical
illness mental illness addiction when we
housed them we found that overall
healthcare costs including the housing
decreased that's because they had many
fewer hospital visits both in your
emergency room and on the inpatient
service and we gave them back their
dignity no extra charge for that for
people who do not have a steady support
supply of food especially those who are
diabetic safety net systems are
experimenting with a variety of
solutions including food pantries at
primary care clinics distributing maps
of community food banks and soup
kitchens and in New York City we've
hired a bunch of enrollers to get out
patients into the supplemental nutrition
program known as food stamps - most
people when patients and doctors don't
understand each other mistakes will
occur for non-english speaking patients
translation is as important as a
prescription pad perhaps more important
and you know it doesn't cost anything
more to put all of the materials at the
level of fourth-grade reading so that
everybody can understand what's being
said but more than anything else I think
low-income patients benefit from having
a primary care doctor mind you I think
middle-class people also benefit from
having somebody to quarterback their
care but when they don't they have
others who can advocate
for them who can get them that
disability placard or make sure the
disability application is completed but
low-income people really need a team of
people who can help them to access the
medical and non-medical services that
they need
also many low-income people are
disenfranchised from other community
supports and they really benefit from
the care in continuity provided by
primary care a primary care doctor I
particularly admire was once told me how
she believed that her relationship with
a patient over a decade was the only
healthy relationship that that patient
had in her life the good news is you
don't actually have to be a doctor to
provide that special source of care and
continuity this was really brought home
to me when one of my own long-term
patients died at an outside Hospital I
had to tell the other doctors and nurses
in my clinic that he had passed but he
didn't know that in another part of our
clinic on a different floor there was a
registration clerk who had developed a
very special relationship with my
patient every time he came in for an
appointment when she learned three weeks
later that he had died she came and
found me in my examining room tears
streaming down her cheeks talking about
my patients and the memories that she
had of him
the kinds of discussions that they have
had about their lives together my
patient had a hard life he was by his
own admission a gangbanger he had spent
substantial amount of time in prison he
suffered from a very serious illness he
was a drug addict but despite all that
he really missed a visit and I like to
believe that was because he knew at our
clinic that he was loved
when our healthcare systems have the
same commitment to low-income patients
that that man had to us two things will
happen
first the system will be responsive to
the needs of low-income people it will
speak their language it will meet their
schedules it will fulfill their needs
second we will be providing the kind of
care that we went into this profession
to do not just checking the boxes but
really taking care of those we serve
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]